bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 rue de culture et
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
à 8 novembre chanter pour ne pas oublier
le festival plein f'art humanité de
retour à la verrière deux jours de
concerts au scarabée en faveur des
victimes du terrorisme faire découvrir
l'opéra dès l'âge de 8 ans et la volonté
du carrosse doré d'arsenaux va leur
nouvelle création l'éblouît se joue au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'au 11 novembre
on y suit les jambes mais pour seul sur
d'autres noirs et un autre regard sur la
nature une invitation à la contemplation
l'artiste plasticien mildiou exposé à la
maison triolet aragon jusqu'à la fin du
mois vous fera découvrir ses créations
durant deux jours dans une partie du
château de versailles résonnaient des
notes et derrière les instruments de
jeunes yvelinois ils font partie de
l'orchestré des mots ce dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale un sujet réalisé avec
marie pannetrat
[Musique]
rabia et maïs habite la verrière et rêve
de faire de la musique
elle commence la deuxième saison du
programme demos et apprennent la flûte
traversière auprès des professionnels de
la philharmonie de paris
il a travaillé la voie et on a commencé
à apprendre de ma musique à moi j'aime
bien la musique
il rêve de faire de la musique
[Musique]
oh
à
comme elle une centaine d'enfants
évinois s'entraîner vendredi 27 octobre
au château de versailles auprès de
professionnels cette commune font partie
de l'orchestré demos on apprendre de
nouvelles choses
on apprend des did not nouvelle note
l'idée de demos est de s'adresser à des
enfants issus de quartiers politique de
la ville qui a priori aurait pas fait de
musique par ailleurs et de leur donner
un instrument pendant trois ans qu'ils
vont apprendre en groupe donc par petits
groupes de 2 15 deux fois par semaine
et puis une fois toutes les six semaines
ils vont se réunir en grand orchestre de
100 enfants environ et travaillé toute
l'année un programme musical quatre
heures hebdomadaires de travail pour ces
enfants âgés de 7 à 12 ans au programme
de cette année la bacchanale de camille
saint saëns l' orchestre yvelinois donne
rendez vous en juin pour un concert à la
philharmonie de paris
en plateau avec nous car ils jacquemod
et benjamin blain on va parler de la
deuxième édition du festival play for
humanity organisées par diverses
associations ça se passe au scarabée à
la verrières né c'est au profit des
victimes du terrorisme
benjamin blain vous êtes membre du
groupe b bly qui se produira sur scène
construction et karim jacquemod vous
vous êtes membre de l'organisation
oui une étudiante qui participent à
l'organisation il ya une particularité
alors cette année encore dans les
yvelines
et il ya de date le vendredi et le
samedi le 11 novembre c'est plus du
métal il ya un show time marne looking
for media ou encore même si ben ça c'est
ça il ya aussi deux autres groupes
éleveurs hyde et barracuda qui sont tous
des groupes qui ont été bénévole en fait
pour participer justement à cette date
et donc voilà ça va se passer à la
verrière et d'ailleurs on voulait aussi
remercié la salle du scarabée et la
mairie de la verrière qui sont
partenaires de l'événement et du coup on
à la salle gratuitement donc ça aide
beaucoup pour alors le ça faisait du
métal le vendredi est plutôt de la pop
rock alors il a notamment romain eu des
taux c'est l'un des parents de cette
nouvelle édition
oui c'est ça on l'a il a été choisi
parce que basséen
jeune artiste déjà il a commencé sur
internet dont il représente assez bien
la jeune génération
il a déjà été dans deux groupes avant
cela faisait 10 19 10 et sort son
premier album bientôt donc c'était une
bonne occasion de faire participer
alors pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
on va regarder un petit extrait partir
pour respirer un peu s'enfuir de vent
dans les cheveux sur la route pour se
retrouver les
juste un retard je vois que malgré le
flou juge déjà que l'on vivra là bas
bonjour ne vivrai que
[Musique]
alors vous voyez ghettos se produira le
vendredi 10 en début ou en fin de
concert là pour l'organisation je suis
absolument pas d'accord alors rien le
pahun c'est le groupe la archimède alors
il faut préciser qu'ils sont pas là sur
les dates yvelinoise oui on pourra les
écouter le 24 novembre au gibus de paris
le 25 à villeurbanne parce que cette
année le festival s'agrandit on n'est
pas cela est venu et 7ème demande des
verts alors ça je sais pas vraiment en
fait on n'a pas à parler pour ce qu'on
avait à faire mais ça permet de toucher
plus de gens de récolter plus d'argent
du coup l'année dernière il avait réussi
à reverser 9500 euros aux associations
ça sur deux jours de concerts et déjà
prometteur donc du coup cette année je
pense qu'ils veulent agrandir le
festival pour justement récolter
récupérer plus de faux alors là ce sont
des groupes qui sont déjà connus qui ont
déjà leur public qui fondent et des
scènes assez reconnus mais aussi il y
aura des groupes locaux c'est le cas de
bébés donc je me tourne vers vous
benjamin vous êtes mort patients ainsi
que tous vos copains et vous êtes le
chanteur et guitariste du groupe elle
vous pourrez vous écoutez les 10 et 24
novembre exactement nous on a eu la
chance d'être sélectionné pour la date
du du scarabée ont pour ouvrir cette
soirée et puis du coup on nous a recalé
le le 24
nous dire quel est le 24 pour vous
écouter c'est un peu plus de sel il ya
eu un concours pour trouver des groupes
locaux comme ça ya un coût qui a été
organisé pour trouver des groupes qui
ferait la première partie d'archimède
justement pendant les dettes du 10 et du
24 puisque le 25 du ca lyon c'est un peu
plus compliqué pour faire déplacer les
artistes sont tous les locaux baby c'est
un trio rock alors avec vous il ya
guillaume à la base fabien la batterie
le groupe a même pas 10 ans quand vous
êtes presque un peu tout jeune est votre
dernière opel lui qui sort carrément au
mois de novembre le 24 précise
exactement bac il faut en fait
transmettre à la sortie de l'opus sur la
date du gibus donc c'est je pense que
c'est un peu pour ça qu'on a été nous en
hausses iront ils ont un peu aidé là
dessus pour nous donner un peu de
visibilité
un beau style rock j'ai cru comprendre
un peu l'insoumis en fait c'est de la
chanson française avec des guitares un
peu musclé donc voilà mais ça reste ça
reste poli parce que ça donne
[Musique]
omer déficit
tout ça sert
je
je voulais tourner
[Musique]
alors ce qu'on vient d'entendre c'est
déconne c'est le premier titre du nouvel
album et c'est voilà j'ai le même nom
d'ailleurs de le paix voilà cinq titres
de ce ça fait longtemps vous travaillez
c'est en fait on
à la base on devait pas faire un ep on
devait faire un album mais sur plus de
temps et l'année dernière et ça s'est
goupillé bizarrement du coup on est
parti sur quatre titres
ce qu'on avait une opportunité d'aller
enregistré dans un studio super super
cool avec quelqu'un de super affûté vous
avez préféré alors on a préféré couper
la deadline et y aller avec ses 4 titres
alors vous savez je participer à un
complot mais pourquoi vous avez
lui participé à ces concerts il ya
l'aspect un peu bénévoles exactement bas
ça nous touche tous un ce genre de
choses nous on est juste à côté on s'est
dit qu'en postulants ont leur coûterait
rien du tout ça nous donne de la
visibilité nous ça nous permet de jouer
dans une super salle parce que le
scarabée c'est clairement une très belle
salle leçon il est très propre et tout
et puis si on peut filer un coup de main
pour remplir
on est là pour ça et karine tous les
fonds seront reversés aux associations
parce que le but du festival c'est
continuer à chanter oui si ça exactement
donc les deux associations qu'on a un
partenaire c'est l'association française
des victimes du terrorisme et l'union
fédérale des anciens combattants et tous
les fonds cours récoltes sont reversés à
ces deux associations
merci à tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau le festival play for humanity
débute le vendredi 10 novembre à 19h en
bas de l'écran s'affiche de lien pour
réserver vos places
autre rendez vous musicaux à montigny le
bretonneux françois et les attaques
mountains un groupe aux influences
multiculturelles
ils sont sur la scène jacques brel ce
vendredi extraits
c'est il entend tuer
chaque jour
c'est sûr
j'ai cru
j'ai cru pouvoir la saisir
deux soirées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il vous emmène en orient en arménie
andré manoukian joue à l'église
saint-georges de trappes à un concert en
toute intimité
l'artiste qui a été juré de la nouvelle
star retrouve ses racines arméniennes
ont écouté un extrait de son dernier
album
[Musique]
on ouvre une page exposition nils udo
dialogue sans cesse avec la nature il
lapan la photographie l'artiste passe
plasticien allemand expose actuellement
plusieurs de ses créations à la maison
triolet aragon regarder on dit ring
marqué la dérive
mais en regardant de plus près on
distingue des fleurs de campagne sur une
feuille de châtaignier
nils udo trompe l'oeil du public
l'obligeant à s'arrêter à contempler ce
nom c'est vraiment une poésie de la
nature qui se réalise à travers ça on
serait une patience toujours dans ce
travail là qui a mis énormément de temps
à chaque fois pour réaliser une
photographie là dedans évidemment on
doit rentrer dedans on doit se laisser
faire pour ça pour entrer dans
l'exposition l'artiste allemand est un
pionnier du land art
le mouvement de l'art dans la nature
avec ses photographies comme ses
peintures il représente une botanique
compte steam et personnel
on a l'impression dans l' exposition de
peintures de rentrer comme nous dans une
forêt dense et travers les sous bois on
voit petit à petit notre regard
s'accoutumer et là on distingue quelques
formes des transparents des lumières qui
miroite et le bleu des eaux
nils udo restitue la nature pourrait par
elle-même avec émotion et communion un
instant suspendu
[Musique]
entre 1914 et 1918 près de 8 millions de
français hommes sont appelés pour
combattre les femmes ont aussi dû
participer à l'effort de guerre et elles
sont mises à l'honneur cette année aux
clayes-sous-bois des expositions et des
spectacles retrace des parcours de
femmes durant la grande guerre écouter
montrer la place de la femme y avait
effectivement les au budget et puis
avait aussi seul qui redonnait du moral
aux soldats et puis celles qui prenaient
la place de faire de la famille vraiment
elles ont pu développer leur rôle
surtout les façades des facettes de la
société
en fait aussi bien au travail que dans
la famille les hommes n'étant pas là il
ya une complémentarité des rôles les
hommes sont partis se battre les femmes
ont géré on gérer tous l'assurent le
feront d'ailleurs comme à l'arrière
propos recueillis par camille lambert et
marie pannetrat le centenaire aux
clayes-sous-bois se déroule jusqu'au 19
novembre
horn est un jeune garçon mais à l'âge de
sept ans avec deux trous noirs pour seul
lieu grâce à une rencontre il va
apprendre à porter un autre regard sur
le monde et sur la vie l'éblouît et une
de création du carrosse d'or et d'argent
nova et xavier les gars ça bonjour j
vous signé la mise en scène de cet opéra
à voir à partir de 8 ans voilà comme
tintin la peinture ou 8 ans jusqu'à 77
et plus alors depuis 2011
arseneault vaille carrosse d'or font le
pari de l'opéra jeune public
pourquoi ça d'habitude c'est un art qui
ne s'adresse pas à l'enfance c'est un
art qui s'est adressé à l'enfance
en tout cas dans l'enfance privilégiée
puisque départ c'est une forme qui était
plutôt qu'on donnait dans des dents des
dans des châteaux dans des choses comme
ça ou dans des théâtres un petit public
et puis
effectivement
on a pensé qu'il était intéressant de
présenter aux enfants des histoires
chantées par des chanteurs d'opéra
cirque on utilise jamais de sonorisation
on utilise simplement à la voile eric et
les instruments parce qu'il sait plus on
sera amenés jeunes dans ce genre de lieu
et dans ce genre d'esthétique
puis il sera facile ensuite
d'appréhender le répertoire du mois dire
le grand répertoire de l'opéra c'est un
style que les enfants ne connaissent pas
nécessairement avant d'en parler un peu
plus je vous propose de regarder un
extrait ci
[Musique]
oh
voilà on a vu
on est une petite marionnette parce que
sur scène il ya des chanteurs des
musiciens et du live et des baïonnettes
donc la spécificité de notre travail
c'est que nous sommes chanteur mais
aussi marionnettiste donc ce qui nous
permet de représenter le théâtre avec
des marionnettes mais aussi dans le cas
de louis des rôles incarnés par les
chanteurs eux mêmes voilà alors en fait
c'est horn n'est pas une marionnette il
commence la pièce on pense que c'est une
marionnette c'est un peu de naissances
comme pinocchio et c'est surtout son sa
compagne enfin son ami rob qui est
représenté par une marionnette qui est
une marionnette d'inspiration japonaise
ce qu'on appelle la marionnette boudera
coût qui est une marionnette qui se
manipule a normalement à 3 et là à les
manipuler par 2 par les deux chanteurs
vous parlez du japon parce que quand on
lit vos inspirations vont citer ihome
nasa qui comme référence
on rappelle que sept créateurs notamment
du voyage de chihiro et des prophéties
mononoké mais c'est un comme un dieu
vivant au japon et représente
comme les blues
le parallèle est vraiment très très fort
c'est à dire qu' il va toujours présenté
un conte donc dans un conte on va parler
de choses qui sont pas toujours
agréables on a un petit peu exorciser
nos photos nos soucis alors chez
miyazaki c'est beaucoup comme au japon
le l'apocalypse nucléaire c'est la
pollution la nature voilà le rapport à
la nature etc
il allait j'ai peut-être histoires de il
ya aussi des choses qui ne sont beaucoup
d'humour et des choses ce comics il ya
des choses moins en moins drôle mais en
tout cas il ya un message qui est celui
de dire toujours oui à la vie
parce que voilà quand on est quand on
est aimé et qu'on aime et qu'on aime les
autres c'est un message tout simple mais
titre porteur d'espoir pour les enfants
pour les grands dans un monde qui est
plutôt pas rigolo voilà et d'un point de
vue création vous proposer une mise en
scène assez minimaliste pour peut-être
éviter que les enfants se perd dans des
détails mais c'est une inspiration
japonaise aussi puisque on a assumé le
fait qu on s'inspirait de dé théâtre
traditionnel d'extrême orient donc du
japon comme nous le kabuki et
c'était pour nous de trouver la façon la
plus efficace représente effectivement
pour un public
peut-être qu'il n'est pas trop habitué à
écouter des chanteurs de représenter les
choses simplement mais c'est surtout
pour servir un texte pour servir le
texte de joël jouanneau qui est un texte
qui est un texte aussi épuré enfin un
travail il ya un travail sur les purs
qui est très très très très fort alors
on pouvait pas le présenter d'une autre
façon justement vous l'avez cité joël
jouanneau qui a écrit le livret de cet
opéra mais c'est tiré d'un livre en 2004
qu'est ce qui vous a plu vous en tant
que metteur en scène quand vous avez lu
l'histoire de ce jeune garçon bain puis
ce qui a été intéressant pour nous c'est
de s'attaquer au merveilleux et au magic
et aux politiques on en est venus
d'ailleurs joué nos deux dernières
créations ici ou au théâtre
on était au départ on a plutôt une
formation de comics faire du théâtre
comique de comédie on va dire en fait
plutôt de comédie
sauf que comique et là on avait envie de
se frotter à ces formes poétiques les
merveilleuses et puis on a eu la chance
que joël jouanneau nous adaptant sa
pièce de théâtre pour l'opéra c'est à
dire qu'il a
il est passé d'un texte de 56 pages à 25
pages et puis on est vraiment dans la
tradition d'opéra qui fait qu' on joue
les grands textes de théâtre on les
adapte comme a fait verdi voilà pour ne
citer que lui ou bien mozart il a été
élu à jouer un beau marché des choses
comme ça voilà et un autre nom dans la
création michel musseau je mets la
musique qui reprend le parler chanter we
une taverne au départ l'opéra en fait
c'était on me disait en italien recitar
cantando c'est-à-dire fer et titane et
en italien c'est faire le théâtre et les
italiens pensé qu' il s' interroger
puisque c'était la renaissance donc le
retour à l'antiquité au théâtre grec etc
et ils ont interrogé sur la forme
théâtrale comment on pouvait faire
représenter le théâtre avec de la
musique donc on a chanté sur du texte
et là c'est le compositeur de michel
dussault a vraiment son travail son
souci c'était de toujours respecter le
texte et qu'on puisse entendre le texte
avoir une musique au service de ce texte
voilà merci et xavier légasse alors
l'éblouît est à découvrir jusqu'au
samedi 11 novembre au théâtre national
de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
et celui qui nous parle cinéma cette
semaine c'est luc beaucamp du ciné 7d
l'enclos on écoute alors le coup de
coeur du ciné cette semaine c'est
évidemment l'édition du festival 51
dédié au documentaire avec pour
thématique cette année la musique donc
plusieurs événements ciné set je vais
très vite le vendredi 10 sept
le public pourra voir gratuitement un
très beau documentaire ce qu'ils
savaient ce qu'il faut de silence sur la
jeunesse d'un concerto le samedi 18
soirées spéciales j'assiste à 18h30 sur
youssef le gant brissette l'histoire de
youssef qui a fabriqué lui même ses
instruments de musique qui sera dans la
salle et qui viendra organisé un petit
concert mini concert et le 18 à 10
heures 30 une séance pour les enfants
six courts métrages et la clôture à
partir de 16h où nous diffuserons le
documentaire sur pierre barou et on
assistera à la remise des prix du
festival
et n'oubliez pas de venir découvrir sur
nos écrans cette semaine le très beau
film d'albert dupontel
au revoir la --et du très bon roman de
pierre lemaitre un film exceptionnel les
gens sortent ravis c'est une très belle
adaptation très réussie pour une fois
d'un très grand nombre
un dingue kevin masqué qui dessine à
longueur de journée toujours des
monuments aux morts
[Musique]
le festival saint quentin dont viens
vous parler
l'ubo corps débute le 15 novembre
prochain avec une soirée d'ouverture à
l'ugc skywest l'invité de cette soirée
vladimir cosma le célèbre compositeur de
musique de film le programme complet est
à retrouver sur le site internet du
festival
après la scène le grand écran
l'humoriste belge nawel madani jouer
réalise son premier film c'est tout pour
moi
elle ne présentait la semaine dernière à
l'ugc skywest nous y étions accueil
chaleureux pour nawal madame y
l'humoriste présentait son tout premier
film à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est tout pour moi raconte l'histoire
d'une jeune bruxelloise une fiction
autobiographique 1995 bruxelles
à droite c'est moi il a un ça va
c'était début des ennuis j'ai pas hésité
à aller chercher dans mon histoire
personnelle de temps en temps à aller
puiser dans des événements qui me sont
réellement arrivé et puis et puis
parfois fictionné parce que c'est
compliqué de raconter sa propre histoire
je voulais prendre un recul et puis
surtout qu'il ya des périodes de ma vie
qui ont été beaucoup plus longue dans la
galère exemple 12 ans de galère je vais
déchiré vos passeports
je vais vous envoyer au bled chez ma
mère et vous allez faire du mois qui
auraient cactus mais quinze ans après
j'étais toujours à fond j'avais qu'une
idée en tête a tenté ma chance à paris
[Musique]
une première expérience derrière et
devant la caméra vu un premier film pour
l'artiste belge comme pour la plupart du
casting est toujours où je voulais que
les gens puissent se projeter
s'identifier c'est un lourd challenge et
parce que j'ai eu cinq semaines pour
tourner ce film là lancé les journées
étaient intensive
on a tourné sept minutes jour du film
c'est très laid c'est le rythme d'un
téléfilm
il y avait beaucoup de décors beaucoup
personnage il fallait qu'on s'attache
aux personnages secondaires au temple
est propre d'autant que les personnages
principaux
c'est tout pour moi sera dans les salles
le 29 novembre prochain
le film parle de danse de one man show
mais c'est aussi une histoire d'amour et
celui de sa famille une succès story
pour un message toujours français
ou sans voix
[Musique]
du théâtre pour débuter que le voleur
d'autobus et l'histoire de chérif
voulant rejoindre sa femme jamila
mourante à l'hôpital une pièce de nour
eddine ammar à découvrir au théâtre
espace que je dois plaisir extrême je
suis président je vous jure
je vous jure que je n'ai pas de voler
pour voler on a soulevé le sacré
championne m'a dit que ça elle a dit oui
elle a dit
[Musique]
ils sont pas
lundi je suis tu t'aventures mia je sais
c'est la coutume le barbu serpentine le
soldat a défilé des places à gagner avec
tv 78 le prisme à elancourt c'est pour
tinariwen le collectif touareg marie le
rock et le blues au traditionnel
mélopées saharienne vous pouvez jouer
jusqu'au 22 novembre sur notre site
internet et la librairie le pavé du
canal propose un atelier pop up l'art du
livre en 3d l'animatrice de l'atelier
lna selena est auteure de livre pop up
à l'issue de l'atelier ldk qui cassera
son album jardin bleu le 7-8 culture est
maintenant terminée je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mercredi
prochain
[Musique]